let's get to the big screen reunion that
you will only see here
Michelle Turner is back with us from New
York and Nichelle everybody is talking
about this Nancy why am i in New York
talking about drew Beverly Hills it's
not fair
look all my wilderness girls dreams came
true that day the cast of troop Everly
Hills together again and at the Beverly
Hills Hotel nonetheless just makes me
want to sing Kumbaya break out your
badges and your cookie boxes for a
reunion thirty years in the making
I do want to start out giving you guys a
little gift we got you a little gift is
there a moment that stands out shooting
this to you all 30 years later my cookie
time was
[Laughter]
[Music]
so buy a box and do your [ __ ]
she wasn't lip-synching don't know how
many people come up to you and ask you
to sing that though I get back and I get
excuse me she knows this man is he's the
best he's the greatest he's my dad James
let's Jack him up uh cough phyllis
nefler trip Beverly Hills I do want to
gush about Shelley Long for more than a
second here because for me this role and
I really believe it was underappreciated
in so many ways for a comedic actress I
may be a beginner at some things but
I've got a black belt in shopping the
physical comedy it was so fantastic and
there's a scene where the rain they had
the you know they made it rain I just
love that scene because we're just
cheering you on if we want you to make
it so bad then we have our can fire I
just loved it the coast is not until we
sing Kumbaya I think an improv I feel
like that came up it was an improv
during the table read that's right
that's right
and I just broke into kumbaya and the
Ghostbusters two guys wanted to use
kumbaya but we already have it smell of
cookies in the morning Betty Thomas
played the red feathers villainous
leader Velda right mom Nick's on the mom
business I call you mom dearly so needed
Nick's on the mom business that's right
after to Beverly Hills Betty left acting
and became one of the most successful
female directors in Hollywood
we found at the airport and I start
saying hey hand me that thing there's a
blue light special
tenshun Kmart shoppers I've had people
come up to me young women come up to me
and say oh my god your Velda plunder
that my voice never changed and Tori
this was it was her last acting role it
was your first acting role right blast
for you guys from Mars worse Beverly
Hills obviously I had a small part but I
just loved watching and the costumes
though like I feel like you watched them
now you're like oh my gosh
iconic don't you have a favorite look
Shelley you know the dress with the bird
on the shoulder just pretty you know it
misses the point I have a favor to ask
please and thank you if we could end
with a little Beverly Hills best day
ever
now you may have noticed that some of
the original cast members were missing
but they did send messages including
this one from actress carla Gugino happy
30th anniversary of true Beverly Hills I
can't even believe that I don't think
I've been a lot long enough for that
have you I'm sending a lot
from New York City chica Barney fella
dobri yeah chica barn Feld I love it
that is so sweet
by the way the Beverly Hills Hotel is
offering a package to celebrate the
movies 30th anniversary so you can have
your own troupe experience Nancy you
gotta take your daughter and introduce
her chocolate fantastic oh how fun great
idea I know that she would love it she
was a girl scout
[Music]